hey guys today it is now run by the 25th
my name is Jess and you're watching
dance Putney the open beta the rainbow 6
siege was set to go live this morning
but technical difficulties have resulted
in a delay yesterday Ubisoft told
everybody that the beta would begin at
seven a.m. PT but it seems things didn't
go to plan the developer wrote on the
games forum we're currently seeing
issues with matchmaking times and
disconnection on all platforms as such
we're postponing the beta until a later
time and keeping the game under closed
beta status we apologize for the delay
and can assure you this is our top
priority we will keep everyone updated
regularly as we continue to deploy
improvements gamespot will keep you
updated on when you can actually play
the thing Rainbow six siege is due for
its full release in less than a week on
December one Sony have a new milestone
to tout today as global sales for the
PlayStation 4 have nails the past 30
million units that's a whole lot of
playstation sony has said that the
figure demonstrates the fastest and
strongest growth in PlayStation hardware
history although they adds that it is
partially estimated Sony's best-selling
console of all time is still the ps2
which sold more than 155 million units
in its 12-year stint on the market while
the ps3 has sold 18 million units during
its lifetime the ps4 sales milestone was
achieved shortly after price cuts took
place across North America Australia
Japan and Europe and finally today EA
has announced that star wars battlefront
is the largest a digital launch in the
company's history the publisher added
that battlefront also marks the biggest
launch of any Star Wars game ever
released although no specific figures
were given EA Studios exec Patrick
soderlund revealed in a blog post that
lots of new content is due to arrive the
battlefront in the coming months he
added that there are going to be more
free updates for the game arriving after
the upcoming
battle of jakku expansion in addition to
the paid content coming in the season
pass you should let me know what you
think about the rainbow 6 siege beta
delay down in that comment section you
can have the game spot we've got news on
the new steam sale and December's
PlayStation Plus game that is everything
I have for you today but as always let
me know what mattered to you and I will
catch you again tomorrow